I mean I sit on a number of charities on
the board of a number of charities that
are doing fantastic work in Africa and
I'll come into details in a moment but I
think what's really important to stress
here again is what these charities can
and cannot do
so the charities that I sit on are able
to go into these countries and actually
provide band-aid solutions intermediate
solutions they cannot provide jobs which
is where it's really important for us to
see much more involvement in the private
sector and that's why I'm talking about
this other form of aid and and why it's
it's hamper that that opportunity some
of those charities that I think are
doing some fantastic work our places
like room to read which has got a very
targeted programs towards helping young
people get access to books other
charities for example I sit on the board
of a charity called London for Africa
which is a very very clearly defined
mandate to try and support it by through
lending projects in microfinance across
the continent and the third strategy
that I work for or whose I'm a patron
for whom I'm a patron it's called Ark
absolutely turned for kids again very
targeted involvement providing
antiretrovirals to African Africans in
across Africa but again very narrow and
also no illusion that they are going to
be providing long term sustainable
growth to these to these countries so
there's some examples of some some
interesting programs
well the to the extent that we know what
we're not going to achieve those goals
which is obvious 2015's around the
corner you know the architects of the
Millennium Development Goals are
themselves going around saying that you
know Africa is likely not to meet any of
those goals so I think those type of
very sort of large big scale large focus
lofty goals tend to me to be to be red
herrings for the fundamental issues what
I'm looking to see is much more active
programs to implement the things that we
know work the things that have made
China China and India and South Africa
and Botswana successful at creating jobs
and reducing poverty that's what we need
to focus our efforts on I think it's
also important that we focus on spinning
a more positive story about Africa too
many of the NGOs and celebrities and
charities around are very focused on
perpetuating a negative stereotype about
the concept which cannot be helpful to
raise the very young Africans that are
coming up across the continent that is
of no value to be negative and yet
that's what we see across the continent
so I think we just need to do more of
what we know works and less of what we
know does not work in fact there is no
country on earth today that has achieved
economic development and reduced poverty
by relying on aid not a single one and
yet we're pushing a product that we know
doesn't work at a time when we know what
does work and that's what the issue is
here
absolutely microfinance is one of the
tools for development that I talk about
in the book it is it's an amazing
amazing way of providing support to
Africans and people all around the world
to finance them themselves and therefore
be able to stand on their own two feet
they can provide themselves with an
income provide education and health care
to their children there are numerous
examples of this Muhammad Yunus won the
Nobel Prize for Grameen Bank and I just
was on a on a discussion of program with
him not too long ago even in this market
he's you know with all the the
challenges of the capital markets right
now he's managed to raise 1 billion
dollars from the very small aid come
with students in very small communities
within Bangladesh it's a billion dollars
in rural Bangladesh and you know very
very low default rates and you know
tremendous success these are the type of
programs that should be coming out of
the multilateral institutions and
they're not we're seeing more of the
same giving more money to African
governments giving money to governments
around the world whereas it seems to me
we know what works and Kiva is another
example I talked about in the book it's
an internet interface 420 minimum of $25
you can lend to an entrepreneur anywhere
around the world again helping to
finance a job and again lending is the
operative world word gives an
opportunity for African Africans on the
grounds to actually meaningfully change
their lives
you